I'm Mary Kish and this is a game spot
news update if you were looking for a
sequel to the post-apocalyptic hit the
last of us you may be in luck it looks
like voice actor nolan north may have
outed Naughty Dog's secret and we're
happy for that during metrocon North the
voice of Nathan Drake was asked if he
was working on any other projects with
naughty dog after uncharted for a
thief's end he replied for now uncharted
4 is the last one I know they're doing
the last of us too but my character in
The Last of Us dot dot dot untimely
demise creative director Neil druckmann
has spoken briefly in the past about
doing a sequel to the critically
acclaimed survival game saying that
there is a 50-50 chance that a sequel is
happening I like those odds if North is
right then it sounds like the odds are
starting to sway in our favor but that's
not all North shared during metrocon
visceral project with Amy Hennig at the
helm sounds like it's shaping up to be a
star wars like uncharted similar to 1313
the cancelled third person action game
by lucasarts there's still no official
confirmation of a sequel at this point
but if we find out anything you'll be
the first to know do you think there's
gonna be a sequel to The Last of Us and
what are they gonna name it let me know
in the comments below and for everything
else news be sure to head to gamespot
com
you